started
um
our next speaker is ian ma
he's a
assistant professor at the harley so
glue data science institute at
university of california san diego
before that he was at google research
and
and then before that a postdoc here in
berkeley
uh uh he got his phd university
washington oh yeah uh um
he is an expert on many aspects of
machine learning uh with a particular
emphasis on bayesian inference in high
dimension
and today's talk is about the
convergence of langevin and when is it
dimension independent all right thank
you centos uh thank you so much for the
generous introduction
and i want to thank all the
organizers of the workshop for pulling
this off
it's it's been trying time um
so
today i want to talk about uh a problem
that i've been started thinking about uh
during my time at berkeley um and it's
partially motivated by centaur's talk
back then and that is when is the
convergence of the larger algorithm
dimension independent uh so the previous
work with wen long was actually along
this line of thinking we were trying to
improve the dimension independent
dimension dependence of the convergence
time of the longer arguments and in this
talk i'm going to take a composite
optimization viewpoint so that we make
the convergence rates tight so that we
can understand
when is the dimension independence not
necessary
okay uh but before before i start i
would like to first acknowledge my
amazing collaborators uh ton zhang from
google research and your friend from
ucsd
um
so this whole program is called
geometric methods for optimization and
sampling um so this work is really
motivated by this whole line of research
we have all been doing on drawing a
parallel between sampling and
optimization
in particular we're trying to establish
now asymptotic convergence rates
borrowing ideas from optimization and
all sorts of different fields
um and uh so andre was here so he was
you know one of the first people to
establish that longevity algorithm has
this parallel with a gradient descent at
least in the continuous limit uh you can
think of it as a gradient flow uh over
the chao divergence when we define the
space to be to take the w2 metric
but there is a conspicuous distinction
between optimization and sampling that
is
optimization doesn't have this dimension
dependence whenever you have convexity
right but sampling does and it's been
bugging me for a long time
um
so this motivates the question we've
been asking during the start of the talk
when is the engineering arguments
convergence time dimension independent
um
so
to address this question uh for strong
economics and the smooth problems on rd
uh entire would say that you know this
dimension dependence is in the diameter
of the problem so it goes with epsilon
right whenever you have a accuracy
dependent you have a dimension dependent
and rochester in the audience she might
she might also agree um
but
i would say that you know
this is a compelling argument and in the
worst case it may very well be true
but beyond the worst case things can be
different
in the sense that if we think about the
receptable case that one lawn just
introduced and if we further assume that
each individual log likelihood is lifted
smooth then there is a way to smartly
initialize so that the initial error
actually doesn't depend on the dimension
so it gives us some hope that um you
know
things may become dimensionally
independent under some of those cases
right
um
so
this is when i started this discussion
with ton zhang
when he asked are you sure that the
convergence rates for the laundry
arguments are tight
i wasn't sure um and
i just said well you know it's a
developing field um we got a lot of help
from optimization experts
um and he said
i feel that authentication methods can
help more um basically he said well at
least for stochastic gradient methods
for sjod it should correspond correspond
better to sgd method
um i didn't know what he meant um but
i started working with him on this class
of ncmc problems
where we had this posterior distribution
of the parameter theta depending on the
data
which is proportional to e to the
negative potential function
and
we'll just note it as p star as the
target distribution
and then it's comprised of a likelihood
function
so we can write it as proportional to e
to the negative temperature inverse
times f function where temperature is
defined by one over the number of data
points so then this function becomes the
empirical risk corresponding to
optimization literature
and this prior is negative temperature
negative one over temperature times this
regularizer
and this regularizer is oftentimes
simple
and tractable
so that we can do all sorts of
maneuvering with it
and the hard part is this empirical risk
so we mark this with a with a red color
and mark the regular as a blue color so
that it's benign
um and in this case um
we'll talk the outline of the talk will
be we'll first describe describe some of
the previous approaches and we'll
describe a composite optimization
approach
and then and then we'll consider two
cases one is that this f function this
uh coming from the likelihood is convex
and lip just continues
and then this g function is strongly con
x
um
and another case corresponds better to
the previous talks which is f plus g
function is strongly complex and
lipschitz is smooth
okay let's start with some of the
previous approaches this will just be a
review for for all of us
um
so in this approach
we would usually describe discretize the
longevity dynamics which preserves the
posterior distribution so that the
continuous dynamics is just gradient
flow plus the brown motion
and it's equivalent to the vector field
so that we take at every point
following this current p distribution
this is the negative gradient of ko
divergence when we define the metric to
be the worst time to metric
and
this this implies linear convergence
whenever we have say strong convexity or
log sublux inequality
so this is all well and good
the problem happens when we discretize
it so
after this criticization this is the
gradient descent plus a gaussian random
variable
um so it's equivalent just like well
talked about
to
put plugging in this previous iterate
into this gradient of u
and then integrate everything treat it
as a constant right
um so this is equivalent to
taking at time t
a sort of modified gradient right where
on the upper side we have gradient of
log pt taken over at c the t but on the
bottom side we have gradient of log p
star taken at a previous degree it's
like
the gradient is evaluated at different
points it's like
we have two paths one path tells you
that you should follow this windy curvy
part and integrate it explicitly another
animation takes a while
so another is telling you that you're
just putting a initial sort of initial
point computer gradient follow this
straight line and and go there right of
course there's going to be discrepancy
and this discrepancy
can oftentimes be described as
expectation of norm squared
of this difference and
so note that theta t minus theta k comes
from this difference in this normal
random variable right so
the variance of this normal random
variable scales with dimension d so
that's why we always get this dimension
dependence
um
so at this point a lot of
optimization experts would ask me
why don't you skip the continuous part
just do the discrete time just take the
discrete time perspective all right why
do we always go into this trouble and
then you have this dimension sentence
um
so there is one work that previously
tried to address this this is by alan
dervis and his collaborators
what the approach they took was the
following
so they were the decompose the chao
divergence into two parts
one is the self-entropy
another is the cross-entropy right
we we overuse this used to denote this
functional
over the distribution of p
so
they take they took this composite
optimization viewpoint
so that
you can decompose the chao divergence
and also decompose this longitude
algorithm into two parts one part is the
gradient the same part
and it can also be proven to be the
gradient descent over this cross entropy
another part is this doctor random
variable part can be proven to be the
gradient flow over the self-entropy
right and then
so if let's say u is strongly convex and
lipstick smooth
you have the classical result from
optimization right so when because the
left-hand side is bigger than or equal
to zero so you have this exponential
convergence if you do the error
and
the
this h function is self-entropy because
you have geodesic complexity
you also have something
the same as in optimization literature
and this gives you one over t
convergence if you take a telescoping
sun right so
on their own they're all very good um
the problem is that they don't come they
go they don't go go together very well
because they're centered at different
points so when you combine them
uh inevitably there's this discrepancy
so if you're adding
and subtract
a uh
if you're adding a and subtract
um a function that's that's you pk plus
one minus your pk tilde
that goes back
that's also the discrepancy before and
after adding this running motion oh i
think this caution random variable and
due to the variance of this cultural
random variable you still get a
dimension d
right so ty and i have been staring at
it for a while and then someone says why
don't you align the updates differently
so
previously you know you decompose this
update into these two steps one
decreases cross-entropy one decreases
self-entropy you can write it out and
instead of focusing on this block
if you would focus on the blocks before
so it's like you first add a
gaussian random variable and then you
you plug into gradient descent
if you do that
um the analysis can go a little
differently
um so
let's put it up there
and geodesic connectivity of h is the
same so so the update in the cell
entropy is exactly the same
what's different is that
let's let's look at the intuition and
forget about the setting for a moment
let's say let's just assume u is convex
now in this case
so the difference in u is now aligned
with
with this uh with the self entropy and
then the other part is also classical in
convex analysis right so now you can
readily
combine these two so that self-entropy
plus cross-entropy gives you chao
divergence
and then have this update rule
and so like for people familiar with
comex analysis
this directly gives you that if say u.s
electric is continuous this movement is
bounded then adaptive step size of one
over square root of k lead to one over
square root of k convergence rate the
problem of course is uh there's this
initial condition dependence which
depends in turn in on the dimension
right so
now let's look at uh so the setting that
we uh that we talked about that's when
we have a convex and lipsticks
continuous f and astronomic convex
function g
what would happen
so
to remind people f corresponds to the
likelihood and can be complicated g
corresponds to the prior can be simple
so in this case uh
we have three terms in the chaotic
versions we have a g2
we have a g term and f term and now
instead of grouping g and f together we
would group g and the self-entropy
together so that it's a regularized
entropy
and we denote it using the blue color hp
so that the color corresponds to g
and we have this cross entropy term
which is which we denote by fp
so in this case um
instead of
um
so because we're putting g together with
a brown emotion
we sort of directly integrate it so that
it would decrease
this regularized entropy instead of the
self entropy and then
this so the gradient descent over f is
the same it decreases the cross entropy
so a few more words about the first
first line of the update so for g being
a gaussian distribution we already have
explicit result
to solve it and for basic elastic math
kind of like l1 plus l2 regularizer we
also have a explicit kind of form of
expression
and we can solve it efficiently for sort
of coordinate why it's decomposable g
right because that would be like a
constant times number of gradient
evaluations
um
so under this setting
we can sort of
solve pretty easily that this we have we
now have a strong geodesic complexity of
this regularized entropy
so we'll have sort of like we'll have
this exponential convergence now uh if
we only look at the convergence being
this regularized entropy
um and now
and now for the capacity of f we have
the same thing as before
and if we further assume it's g ellipses
continuous
then this is a constant and we can
combine we can take a step size which
matches
these two
so that we can combine them to get a
convergence for chao divergence
right
um
and by taking
uh this step size h to be one over uh
one over scale like one over mk then we
get the classical optimization result
that is
sort of g squared over
over m
over beta m
um
and beta is is one over m
um so
here the best
uh the best h the best initial step size
we can take as infinity because when we
take it then we integrate it
towards the stationary distribution so
it's same as initializing from this
prior distribution right so when we do
that we get that the ko divergence
scales like g over theta m times k
and it translates using telegram
inequality into what is time two
distance to g squared over m squared
so
so this is this is an interesting result
but it's difficult to compare to to the
previous results right because we assume
there's this splitting
uh and when it's
continuous um what
can you ask you sorry please remind me
about what is g and and and the m strong
geodesic convexity also
yeah yes m is the structured asset
connection and by that you mean uh i
mean that this function g is m strong
economics
yeah so because it's like the
regularized entropy um
and f is uh yeah f is g which is
continuous
oh sorry i was going a little too fast i
guess
um
any questions
okay um so let's uh yeah maybe let's
look at something that can relate better
to previous previous results
so
if we we look at the case where f plus g
is strongly convex and lectures smooth
this will correspond better to to the
existing results
so yeah i also remind the the f
corresponds to likelihood that g
corresponds to the prior
so in this case uh for the posterior
distribution
uh proportional to e to the negative
potential
for the for the u function potential
function being beta inverse and strongly
convex and beta inverse l which is
smooth uh we can directly take g to be
you know m over two theta norm squared
this this normal prior because you know
f is equal to beta u minus g is just
convex and it should smooth like
we can't directly do this splitting
so in this case um
this
first line of update rule can be further
simplified to
to be sort of explicit like the
following right it's just this normal
distribution um
and in this case um we we have exactly
the same thing for
sort of going from strong geodesic
complexity of the self entry of this
regularized entropy
and then we also have from convexity of
f
this expression
and now
because we are no longer assuming that f
is uh lipschitz continuous but instead
left is smooth we can we cannot just get
rid of this term
um so instead the difficulty becomes to
bounding this term
um
and to bound this term we can separate
it into two terms one is the difference
between this gradient f taken at theta k
and the gradient f taken at theta where
theta follows the stationary
distribution
and then what's left is theta following
the stationary distribution of gradient
f theta right so this is entirely the
property of this target distribution on
the sample form
and for the first term we can use
geodetic convexity of this regularized
entropy and lipid smoothness of f
to achieve that
this is upper bounded
by
l times the difference in the k
divergence
because there is a
so originally there is a
h h k squared here
so uh putting on top of it we can just
absorb it into the left-hand side term
which has this ko divergence bound
so now everything turns into
uh
everything turns into this bound uh
that's that's entirely a property of the
stationary distribution everything else
uh you can use convex analysis to to to
just to solve it right
um
now so the question is
when is this term dimension depend
independent or dependent
um so assume that this hessian of this
empirical
risk is upper bounded by a
by a matrix
then
the strong log concavity of p star would
imply
that
this term is upper bounded by
trace of this
hessian upper bound squared
and
so
so if in the rich separable case that
one law just talks about which is
activation functions uh over
inner product of theta of parameter
times the data points
in those cases
assuming that
the second derivative of the activation
function is bounded assuming that the
data distributes in a bounded region
then the lipstick smoothness of each
individual log likelihood
is ls times rz
in this case
we can find that
the
the hessian upper bound on the hessian
can be
can be represented as one over n times l
as
sum over this z z transpose
and the trace of the hessian square is
upper bounded by
l s squared times r d squared right so
under this kind of individual log-like
in the individual smoothness of log
likelihood we can achieve that
um so this is stronger than previous
works
um
under the stronger assumption
we can
we can obtain an upper bound
on the grade on the expectation of this
gradient f with respect to the
stationary measure
which does not have a dimensional
independence in it
um
and in this case uh
we can sort of plug in into our previous
iterate iterative inequality
so that uh
we can achieve that the scalar
divergence is sort of
upper bounded by
this this sort of l l square r squared
over m squared um and then
here there's a there's this sort of
initial condition and because we're now
we have this one minus l times h term we
can no longer take h to be to h0 to be
infinity so we do have this initial
condition dependence
and the best we can take for h0 is one
over l
so i'll talk about uh sort of an upper
bound on the initial condition as we
promised at the beginning of the talk
um
so
if we so if we use this sort of
intuition from this lectures cons
beneficiaries continuous case then we
know that we should take the initial
condition as the prior distribution
right so if we do that then we can use
the telegram inequality uh to first
upper bound this was time to distance by
the chao divergence and then we can use
the
log subwoofer inequality to upper bound
the k divergence by this gradient
difference right and because p star
contains g
f and g and p
p tilde theta contains g so the
difference only contains greater than or
f
and cancelling all those beta terms we
see that this directly falls back into
our bound on this at the stationary
right so this directly implies a bound
on the initial condition
that's l squared r squared over m to the
cube
so
plug that back into
our bound
that gives us sort of
l squared r squared over m squared
squared but divided by k squared so it
matches this term which is l square r
squared over n squared
right so that that tells us that taking
k to be sort of l squared r squared over
m squared one over epsilon uh gives our
sort of desired uh
desired accuracy
um
and for sgod um so the first term is the
same um we we get an additional term
which depends on the staccato gradient
variance in the activation function at
the mode
and then this this s is the mini batch
size
so if say
this b square is not too large let's say
it's a scales like
uh the lips the smoothness of this
activation function
then we can actually
set the mini batch size to be n over
sort of l squared r squared over m m
squared or l r over m so that we can
shave off a
condition number of dependents
um
okay so
yeah so that's the
there's a result for the staccato
gradient version of it
um
and so for the future directions um
of course like
one question is
um is there a larger class of problems
which has has no dimension in dependence
right and also can this approach be
combined with accelerated methods and
optimization or higher order integration
methods in mcmc
um so that you know for this class of
strongly context
is smooth problems
i think the tight convergence rate
should be kappa times log one over
epsilon
um so the question is can we combine
this approach with true works to achieve
something like kappa
times one over epsilon to the one over r
first power where alpha can be obturated
large
um
and with that i think i'll just thank
you for your attention
hi and this is a very interesting uh
talk very interesting work and actually
i was just asking andrew today over
lunch about
the following question and it seems like
it's very i should have also asked you
because it
uh i'll ask you now uh so in the second
setup that you looked at like when you
have smooth and strongly convex
do you really need both parts to be
smooth and strongly convex
because it seems like your thing should
also work when f is smooth and g
strongly convex but neither of them has
to be both
yeah it doesn't have to so in the first
setting actually f is not a smooth fs
yeah that's why i it seems like your
whole thing should just work if you have
a
smooth loss strongly convex regularizer
and the reason you would do that even in
the l2 setting is because then you can
do
the elastic net regularizer which will
not be smooth but it will be strongly
convex and you can have a smooth flash
yeah yeah we're actually able to do that
for for the radiant elastic net
yeah very cool sorry maybe i went a
little too fast
[Music]
yeah very nice uh result very nice talk
um i wondering are you familiar with uh
this um work by
hayer like uh
volmers tour like 2014 where they proved
like my last spectral gap in infinite
dimension then it's dimension
independent
uh
like if you're familiar can you talk
about the the type of assumptions they
assume and compare a little bit or
i was hoping you can tell me it's yeah
it's an algorithm called like uh
preconditioned crank nicholson
uh they also assume this composite form
like f plus g where g is exactly
gaussian they know and then yeah they
they put some assumptions on there to
get a result but yeah if you can't send
it we can we can yeah we can talk later
thanks
thanks for the talk uh we know that in
optimization this uh individual smooth
lipsticks smooth conditions usually uh
enables the use of very reduction
algorithms uh is it possible to like
extend your results in the stochastic
reading case and get better about
reduction algorithms
yeah we think so um yeah because because
this uh the reason we use this
individual log
sort of individual smoothness for log
likelihood
it's because we want to do the cardigan
variants of it and yes
to do variance reduction it also
requires this
so what's the
uh dependence on the tolerance like when
you show the kl divergence is less than
up to epsilon is it one or epsilon
oh the the ethanol independence yes yes
it's one let's see
so
so if we look at if we read this yeah
it's one over f oh sorry i mean the
first case when f is decimals
oh um
yeah it's also a one over epsilon okay
okay let's see do you think this can be
improved to like log of one or epsilon
because you actually have a strong
convexity in this setting yeah that was
the question i asked that uh
at last um because i feel like this uh
this dependence should be kappa linear
in kappa and log in one over epsilon
um
the
the copper case this is the smallest
right if it's small yeah for nine smalls
to have a
gas on the lower bound
smooth i don't have a guess
like
i guess if you draw a parallel it's g
over
m but um
i'm not sure about that
um well my guess is like uh
you use a g right it's like a g square
over um
and the
log of one over epsilon yeah it also
depends on the distance you are talking
about
in the nosmos case
because in the non-smooth case
for chao divergence so yeah in the north
smooth case
there is a scaling difference in chao
divergence and w2 distance so in w2
distance currently it's g squared over m
squared
uh maybe it can be improved i'm not sure
because yeah in previous works i don't
see you know any anything beyond that
in optimization like for example sub
gradient or pendulum method you can show
g square over m epsilon yes epsilon is
not in the log but uh
but in sampling
i think there are two kinds of tolerance
one is from optimization the other is
for sampling
the epsilon i mean i'm talking about for
the sampling part
my guess is this part should go into a
log and
in the denominator there may be another
tolerance let's call it delta this delta
may be the one for optimization
um
that's my guess
yeah that is
for example in the
in a work by
intelli rotation and also kevin ten
they have an alternating
sampling framework in that work uh the
sampling tolerance the epsilon goes into
the log
yeah um yeah that is my guess that
ultimately you might be able to achieve
those
thank you very much thanks
[Music]
thank you